rocky our next guests are part of the
dance dynamics tube and they are having
a week-long back-to-school elvis
inspired performance and tonight is
opening night so put on your blue suede
shoes and head on over to downtown
summerlin and here with more information
is co-founder paige melinson welcome and
we have ellie and genesis from the troop
joining us this is really exciting i
love that you guys are doing this tell
us a little bit about dance dynamics and
what you guys are doing so dance
dynamics is a local dance studio in
downtown summerlin we offer classes for
ages 0 all the way up to 18. ballet tap
jazz lyrical musical theater circus
classes acro hip-hop and then we also
have a separate theater department which
is our dynamic production which we put
on full-scale broadway shows and you
guys are paying tribute to elvis i mean
i i feel like when you think of las
vegas you you think of elvis how
how did this come about why did you pick
elvis and tell us what you guys are
going to be doing in his honor so i mean
really it comes down to the the shows
that become available that we can choose
from all shook up was on the list and
between our team we gathered and met and
decided that um for the back to school
elvis would be a great i know his movie
just came out
and so these kids just do a really
really good job at bringing his music to
life in a really funny quirky show now
obviously this is not particularly your
generation of music maybe it's not even
our generation of music but what do you
what do you guys think of elvis how
how do you love his music it's so
timeless he will never go out of style
and that's so
like it's such an honor to
perform the music that this great star
wrote and produced and it's amazing to
carry that on to different generations i
love it you guys are keeping it alive
what inspired you to get involved with
dance dynamics i've always loved
performing and then i found out about
this company and i auditioned for their
show and i've been there ever since last
summer so oh my goodness now this is
happening at downtown summerland tonight
is the first time tell us a little bit
about it yeah so you can find us
on the lawn which is in the backs part
of downtown summerlin closer to the red
rock side um and we put a grand stage
there and it's free and that's what
something is really really cool it's
absolutely free bring a blanket bring a
lawn chair we have vendors that are set
up too so you can grab a snack and watch
these talented kids perform but we also
do have vip seating available for a ten
dollar purchase oh that sounds amazing
now can we get a little uh taste of what
we're gonna be seeing tonight absolutely
okay let's let's listen ally in genesis
i guess when you think about it all the
best things in life seem like magic
music laughing falling in love oh baby
i'm gonna teach you what love's all
about
tonight oh
no
trust me honey everything's gonna be all
right
gotta do it like i do there ain't
nothing to it listen to me baby anybody
can do it all you gotta do is just
let yourself go
now don't be afraid just relax and take
it real slow
cool it baby you ain't got no place to
go
just put your arms around me
real tight enjoy yourself baby
don't fight all you gotta do is just
let yourself go
wow
that was amazing
oh my gosh great job you guys you can
check out all shook up tonight part of
the broadway on the lawn in downtown
summerlin with shows happening nightly
starting at 7 45. great job las vegas
now we'll be right back